بحسب تفاصيل دراسه الاستقصائيه اجرائها
موقع على اكثر من عشره الاف موظفه مدير
فان المدراء التنفيذيين يقضون اكثر من 25
ساعه من الاسبوع في الاجتماعات الدراسه
تقول ان السبب الرئيسي لهذه الاجتماعات
غير المنتجه الاعتقاد الخاطئ انها ستكون
استخداما جيدا للوقت في العمل
الموظفون المشاركون بالاستطلاع يقولون ان
حضورهم يكون في العدد خشيه ان يفوتهم شيء
هام قد يذكر فيما يقول البعض منهم انه ليس
لديهم خيار اخر الا الحضور وبحسب الدراسات
الاخيره فان الاجتماعات غير المجديه تهدر
ما يزيد عن 100 مليون دولار سنويا في
المؤسسات الكبرى ومنذ عشرين عشرين زادت
الاجتماعات الافتراضيه لتصل الى اكثر من
42% فيما يؤكد المدراء التنفيذيون انه
يمكن التخلص مما يزيد عن 46% من
الاجتماعات
[موسيقى]